in Pakistan summer heat the spring stall
is a treat for factory workers
a break from the threat of losing their
jobs is the electricity running these
machines and the stitching material
becomes more expensive
Pakistan is Asia's fourth largest
producer of cotton textiles make up the
bulk of its exports but poor cotton
yields a ban on importing spare parts
and inability of importers to pay in US
Dollars are all contributing to the
industry's decline factories like these
provide almost 40 percent of the
country's jobs but many have either cut
production or are shutting down
political turmoil isn't helping monthly
inflation in May stands at 38 percent
the highest in Asia
inflation is very high we have no hope
can't even afford fruit it's so
expensive now high prices of Commodities
mean we've lost our purchasing power
the value of one US dollar has gone from
110 to over 300 rupees in the last five
years
the Shop's electricity bill is nine
thousand then there is rent and daily
wages of workers the currency has lost
its value the current situation is very
bad many middle class customers can't
afford the prices I've worked for 30
years in the market but never before
witnessed this kind of situation
Pakistan is in a perfect storm because
of politics security and finance
bringing the economy to the brink there
is a balance of payment crisis because
of dwindling foreign reserves which is
fueling a skyrocketing inflation and a
spiraling rupee
Pakistan's been negotiating with the
international monetary fund or IMF for
more than a year but funds have not yet
arrived politicians accuse each other of
creating the mess and strict loan
conditions mean removing subsidies for
the poor the need to pay off Foreign
debt has made growth harder and limited
the country's Financial options the
government is looking at alternative
lenders including China Russia and Gulf
Nations and it's announced a budget it
says is as people friendly as possible
but many people suffering from reduced
subsidies in higher taxes believe it's
unlikely to bring the relief they want
Lahore